ambri bonsoir bonsoir grégory de la
rédaction de tv 70 vous allez nous
parler politique à présent après les
revers essuyés lors des présidentielles
et des législatives les républicains
entre dans une phase de refondation à
laurent banquiers laurent wauquiez a été
élu à la tête du parti de droite avec +2
74% des voix quasi plébiscite aussi dans
les yvelines où il frôle les 68% nicolas
dans quelle situation se trouve le parti
dans les yvelines et bien grégory
actuellement les républicains illinois
sont dans le flou dans les faits c'est
même un parti sans président
départemental même si david douillet
occupe toujours officiellement ce poste
mais depuis sa défaite aux élections
législatives
il a pris ses distances avec la vie
politique aujourd'hui c'est la sénatrice
sophie primas qui est aussi secrétaire
départemental du parti qui gère la
fédération yvelinoise alors l'élection
de laurent wauquiez a entraîné le départ
de plusieurs élus dont xavier bertrand
pour ne citer qu'eux que lui qu'en
est-il dans les yvelines
alors en fait dans les faits les
réserves à paraissait déjà avant
l'élection du président des républicains
le maire de poissy karl olive émettait
des réserves vis-à-vis du parti avec le
maire de saint germain en laye arnaud
péricard il a même créé un mouvement
génération terrain même initiative pour
la présidente du conseil régional
ile-de-france valérie pécresse
avec son association libre et alors
après le scrutin et l'élection de
laurent wauquiez
quelques militants et blinois n'ont pas
hésité à quitter le mouvement mais c'est
une vraiment une minorité et écouter
pierre bédier président du prg et du
conseil départemental des yvelines et
flora sabbagh présidente des jeunes
républicains yvelinois c'était vraiment
les principaux soutiens de laurent
wauquiez dans le département il reste
quand même rassurant écoutez à l'heure
actuelle les jeunes sont plutôt dans le
flou au niveau du département puisque
nous sommes dans une dans une zone
d'incertitude on ne sait pas encore
comment va se recomposer la fédération
néanmoins l'élection de laurent wauquiez
à la présidence de notre famille
politique avec un large score leur
redonne de l'enthousiasmé de l'espoir
valérie pécresse a ses idées très bien
qu'elle les exprime au sein de notre
famille politique qui a vocation à être
plurielle et à rassembler diverses
sensibilités et ça aide toujours été la
vocation de notre parti que d'avoir une
aile plus tôt et sociale libérale et une
elle plutôt gaulliste social je regarde
avec beaucoup d'intérêt
le mouvement concret valérie valérie
pécresse si c'est effectivement un
mouvement à l'intérieur de l air pour
exprimer des idées pour faire que ces
idées soient majoritaires c'est parfait
si c'est à nouveau pour faire du
fractionnisme on sera dans l'opposition
encore très très longtemps et on finira
par disparaître alors l'a entendu
nicolas on comprend que le défi pour
2018 sera de rassembler cette famille
politique du centre et de la droite est
ce que le tableau est aussi assis noir
dans le département la situation n'est
pas non plus catastrophique dans les
yvelines si la fédération connaît des
difficultés
il ya quand même les élus locaux qui
font qu'ils font la force du parti
encore un succès politique comme vous le
savez en septembre lors des sénatoriales
une majorité au conseil départemental ou
encore quelques grandes agglomérations
du département sous l'étendard des
républicains
conseiller municipal d'opposition
attrapé président du groupe les
républicains et indépendants au conseil
régional vous l'avez reconnu c'est
othman nassr ou croient en leurs la
reconstruction de sa formation à partir
du territoire la gestion qui est celle
des yvelines du département d'un certain
nombre de collectivités nombreuses dans
ce département la haye les scènes et les
saluer par par les habitants et les
maires qui sont en place qui sont des
mères souvent des maires de droite sont
reconnus pour la qualité de leur travail
cette réalité là elle est toujours là
elle est toujours en vigueur
c'est ce que c'est le socle de ce qui va
nous permettre peut-être demain de
rebondir et de dire voilà ce que c'est
que d'être de droite parce que c'est que
de travailler d'être engagé comme un
citoyen comme élu local dans les
yvelines
l'élection du prochain président les
républicains dans les yvelines est
prévue pour octobre 2018
certains imaginent déjà une candidature
de pierre bédier
merci nicolas pour cette chronique on